okay second night in a row livestream
welcome a lot to talk about and a lot of
a lot of housekeeping things to go over
a lot of requests people already getting
messages deleted we fortunately so last
night on the stream someone had asked
about moderation
YouTube being YouTube moderators and I
mentioned if you want to be a moderator
on our YouTube channel get in touch with
me and I will do a full full review
probably as extensive as the review that
concluded that Jared Kushner should not
have a security clearance and we did
that and we have some new YouTube
moderators which should keep the
riffraff down I see that Sabrina one of
our new moderators is already taking
care of business and cleaning things up
in the chat which is really good they've
been fully deputized they know what
trolling is I know what trolling is the
trolls probably know what trolling is
and we're going to we're gonna keep it
to to a minimum we're gonna keep it to a
dull roar I am going to talk about the
fifth fifth time this week or since last
week rather that Republicans have acted
to prevent the release of Robert molars
investigation report three to four
hundred pages 350-400 who knows what's
50 pages between friends 50 pages in
which a lot of negative things can be
said so we're going to talk about that I
see people in the chat asking if I am
going to take a challenges chest
challenges maybe I will I don't know we
might do that I'm David Pakman on Leach
s org and we'll see maybe I will take
some chess challenges maybe if the phone
lines get open and sadly we have now had
after like 14 or so live streams in a
row where we hit a fundraising challenge
and open the phone lines we've had two
live streams in a row during which we
failed as it says down there to get ten
new members during the stream and I have
not opened the phone lines and it's been
kind of sad but I need to stick to it if
we have a fundraising challenge and we
don't meet it I can't just throw out the
challenge and say let's open the phone
lines and I just caught actually it's so
funny
the beginning of the month I get our
sort sir phone bill from the previous
month the phone system that we have for
taking live calls and sometimes when we
take live calls there will be 40 or 50
people holding sometimes for 30 40 or 50
minutes that mean if 40 people hold for
40 minutes that's 1,600 minutes of time
that we're paying for and we had a
record-high phone bill in March because
we did have so many live streams during
which we took phone calls but we will we
will see about that
a little bit later so welcome if this is
your first david pakman show livestream
this is different than the video clips
that we upload because this is live
unless it's a replay actually had some
people yesterday on the stream who
thought they were watching a live stream
but they were watching the archived
version and so they signed up for
memberships hoping to open the phone
lines and the live stream had long ended
it ended hours before and then they
emailed me and said you know you didn't
mention my name and it's because you
were watching a replay if it's 703 p.m.
eastern US time on April 4th it's live
otherwise you're probably watching a
replay I will take your questions and
comments the best thing is to use super
chat super chat is the dollar sign below
the chat window it will pop up your
question or comment on screen I will
read it I will respond to it it'll be an
amazing time for everybody and of course
I am open to taking phone calls if we
get 10 new members you can sign up on
our website david pakman.com slash
membership you can also use the join
button down below the YouTube window
although we get more of the cash when
you sign up on our website on our
website we just pay two point nine
percent payment processing YouTube takes
30 percent of memberships so just bear
that in mind and please don't troll the
live chat as I said we have new
moderators since yesterday some people's
messages have already been deleted I see
that our moderator Sabrina is in the
action I see that our moderator ex is
the leading people's message it's just
out of curiosity let's see what messages
were deleted David's a Jew that supports
Israel and their lobbies heavily
um and what else did he say
is calling David a pac-man trolling yeah
I think it is I don't think that's an in
good faith comment so I mean I don't
know you can leave it that that's I
don't know that I would have deleted
that but I understand it Andrew called
for the execution of Donald Trump for
treason yep we can't allow that
those are calls for violence so Sabrina
was completely spot-on
so far the moderators doing very very
well and Daniel is here as well Daniel
longtime moderator so three moderators
we'll see how many we need it's unclear
how many we're going to need tonight but
it could be quite a few okay so let's
talk about what's going on with this
once again Republican attempt to prevent
the Moller report from getting out of
course the article I'm looking at is
from the hill and it is completely toxic
and riddled just everywhere everywhere
with ads and I I don't use ad sometimes
people ask me why I don't use ad blocker
and the reason I don't use ad blocker is
because I'd be sort of hypocritical the
David Pakman show is ads supported on
YouTube so I feel as though on the one
hand if I'm asking people to sit through
ads for our content so that we earn
money and then I'm blocking ads I feel
like I'm a bit of a hypocrite so I don't
use ad blocker but this is this is toxic
I mean look at it's just ads everywhere
as far as the eye can see but let's get
into the meat of it rather than
discussing the ad Senator Rand Paul
Republican has blocked a resolution
calling for special counsel Robert
Mulder's report on the Russia probe be
made public marking the fifth time fifth
time Republicans have blocked the
house-passed measure Senator Mark Warner
a Democrat from Virginia the vice
chairman of the Senate Intel committee
asked for unanimous consent on Thursday
to pass the resolution which cleared the
house in a 422 0 vote earlier this year
what we are talking about is basic
transparency let's make sure the full
molar report is released to Congress and
then let's make sure the American people
see as much of this report as possible
some people don't know these unanimous
consent provision under Senate rules any
one senator can request that any bill or
resolution be passed but because it
requires the sign-off of
every senator anyone senator can also
block their request
it was indeed Rand Paul who objected
because Warner wouldn't agree to amend
the non-binding house-passed resolution
to include provisions calling for the
public release of communications between
several Obama era officials including
President Obama former FBI director
James Comey and former CIA director John
Brennan of course that has nothing to do
with this report and this is why you
know this is how we get nothing done in
American politics we get a bill put
together for infrastructure and some
senator comes in and wants to add an
amendment which says we also need to ban
abortion or whatever and then any normal
person realizes what that what are those
things what are those two things have to
do with each other they have absolutely
nothing to do with each other and then
you end up with debate and a bill not
being passed that should be passed if
the question here is should the Moller
report be made public or should it not
be made public
you can separately argue if what you
want are Obama era communications to be
released make a proposal Rand Paul but
don't say that you're going to vote
against the release or block it's
non-binding by the way a non-binding
resolution to release the Moller report
because you want Obama era
communications released we should see
the report it's abundantly clear that
the report has damaging stuff in it to
Donald Trump he now gets it he being
Donald Trump who has now backed off of
oh release that it also have released
the whole thing doesn't bother me now
it's it's a distraction and it's all
absolutely and completely wacky when we
know why because it's got damaging stuff
in it and it's pathetic and absolutely
disgusting what is going on let's see
what else is relevant here Paul has
warned that he would block the
resolution backing the Moller reports
release unless information about the
opposition research dossier compiled
against Trump was also released
he first blocked the House passed
resolution last week Rand Paul you know
broken clocks are right twice a day
which i think is sort of the best
analysis of
Paul and he is sometimes right but he is
completely off the rails on a lot of
this stuff claiming it was so scandalous
the dossier and unverified that it has
turned out to be an has turned out to be
untrue and yet this was the basis for
the beginning of the investigation wrong
this was the basis for doing something
extraordinary also wrong what we have
here based on what Rand Paul is saying
is the narrative that the entire
investigation was started on shaky and
possibly illegal or improper pretenses
or a pretext that it was carried out in
a way that was inappropriate and that if
we are to see the molar report the
product of that investigation we also
have to go back and look at Obama
communications which actually may be
governed by executive privilege Donald
Trump plans to assert executive
privilege to get a whole bunch of the
Moller report redacted or his Justice
Department plans to when there may
actually be executive privilege reasons
why these communications Rand Paul is
talking about shouldn't be released the
guy's upside down completely and totally
upside down once again this is the fifth
time Democrats have tried to pass the
House Resolution which says there is
overwhelming public interest in the
government releasing the contents of the
report the resolution calls on the
Justice Department to fully release the
report to Congress and to release it to
the public except to the extent the DES
public disclosure of any portion thereof
is expressly prohibited by law they want
to go way way way beyond that and there
was this phrase I had it in the notes
for today's show let me see if I can
pull them up um there was a category of
redactions
that William bar said they were going to
do let me see if I can find it here what
was the exact phrase that he used yes
they're planning to redact anything that
would unduly infringe on the personal
privacy and reputational interests of
her referral third parties understand
that let me see if I can I can't put
that on the screen if you are going to
say that from the eventual version of
the Moller report that you release
anything that will potentially infringe
on the reputation of only peripherally
involved third parties that is a license
to redact just about anything which is
exactly what they're planning to do and
as Chuck Rosenberg former prosecutors
said yesterday you don't need four
hundred pages to say that Donald Trump
did nothing wrong you don't need to
redact for national security things that
relate to the reputational future of
peripherally involved third parties we
get what's going on we totally
understand it and now the fifth time
that they are trying to block this from
coming out um related to this as I
mentioned this more earlier this
afternoon on the broadcast program there
are now individuals from Robert Muller's
team who say that the report is more
damaging than William bar has revealed i
I don't like doing victory laps because
I think it's stupid I just want the
truth okay but when the bar letter first
came out a week and a half or I guess
closer to two 10 11 days ago whatever
last Sunday not this past Sunday but the
previous Sunday when William bar put out
this letter anyone with an iota of
common sense understood that William bar
put out a press release what William bar
put out was not a summary of the
investigation what William bar put out
was not a document meant to capture the
full scope of how damaging the
investigation is or maybe to Donald
Trump it was a public relations document
I got a call last week during live calls
saying David don't you think that if
Barr was misrepresenting Muller's report
Moeller would be out there saying it and
the answer is no Muller didn't say a
word
during the entire investigation we had
one or two clarifications
from a Muller spokesperson during the
investigation we have no reason
whatsoever whatsoever to believe that
Robert molar would be out screaming that
William bars letter is incomplete but we
now have heard from some on Muller's
team who say William bar is not
accurately characterizing the level of
damage that this in this full report
could do to Donald Trump and anyone with
an ounce of common sense anyone with a
shred of rationality would understand
that you don't need 400 pages to say
Trump did nothing wrong Moeller could
not exonerate Donald Trump from
obstruction so once again do I think
that personal proactive collusion is
going to be proven on the behalf of
Donald Trump no I said a year ago I
don't think that that's the case a year
ago direct quote I believe there is
almost a zero percent chance that that
happens but the idea that Donald Trump
has been totally exonerated by this is
laughable absolutely and completely
laughable I won't go over all of the
details of that story now because we
have a video clip that has either
already published or will be publishing
to the YouTube channel so I don't want
to redo that for people who have already
listened to or watched today's program
okay before I see a ton of messages from
people and people who want to play
against me in chess and I'm are I got
already three challenges on HS org the
chess stuff is gets very mixed review
sometimes people like it when I will
take a challenge or two from people in
the audience and play chess other people
hate the chess it's like when I did the
segment the other day where I told you
some of the books that I've been reading
some people love it some people hate it
so I see people are challenging me on LY
chess org we'll see about that if we get
like a really big super chat from
someone who says I'm sending the super
chat because I want to play you--only
chess maybe I'll do it or maybe if we
open the phone line so that that's one
thing I also want to say thanks to some
new members let's see here Jeremy
Gifford is this evenings first new
member new member number one of the
evening is Jeremy Gifford and new member
number two of the if evening is Antoine
Remillard we are at two out of ten okay
if we get 10 new members tonight I'll
open up the phone
lines I'm not gonna lie it would call
into question the success of these live
streams if we go three live streams in a
row without opening the phone lines and
I don't want that to happen so by all
means take advantage of the coupon codes
that are down in the video description
we are at two out of ten and I hope we
get to ten before you know it and the
phone lines will be open let's go to
some of the super chats that are coming
in Oh actually carry 81 has become a
YouTube member so that's number three so
we're actually at three out of ten
towards opening the phone lines Thank
You Kerry appreciate that enter name
says F marry kill Hillary Clinton
Chelsea Clinton Whoopi Goldberg you know
enter name I think I'm gonna skip that
one I think I'm gonna skip that one I
did an F marry kill yesterday but I
think it would be unbecoming of the
program for me to start doing F marry
kills all the time so I'll skip it
publicly but email me privately I know
and I'll give you my answers on that one
I saw by the way I don't know that I've
maybe I shouldn't even be saying this
but I saw Whoopi Goldberg do an hour of
comedy at a an invitation-only event let
me put it that way and it was not good
it really wasn't good and I love Whoopi
Goldberg and I think she's great and I
like a lot of her politics and some of
her movies are great and all of that
stuff but her hour of comedy ended up
being 20 minutes of mediocre material
and then taking increasingly poor
questions from the audience for the
remaining 40 minutes it was not good
Nouvel coast says you mentioned you both
agree and disagree with Anna K on
various issues as both the young turks
viewer and long-term packrat curious on
which issues you differ I actually don't
know so what what this user what this
viewer is a user sounds like a drug user
I meant YouTube user a user of the
YouTube platform really digging here
what this viewer is asking about is that
I did a segment yesterday where I
pointed out that what the treatment ana
kasparian has been receiving as a result
of a piece she did on tulsi gabbard is
completely unfair
and I made a point to say during that
segment that this is not about Ana is
someone that I agree with ever with on
everything politically but actually
didn't have anything in mind I don't
watch enough of any other show to really
know her views on any particular issues
of disagreement I just mean it doesn't
matter whether we agree or disagree on
every issue I'm guessing there are
issues we disagree on I don't know what
they are but the way she was treated
smeared after her Tulsi Gabbard video
was just disgusting
Matthew Upchurch says David do you have
a sponsor a member program we do in a
couple different ways so number one when
you go to our website and you sign up
you can enter anyone's name and email
address when you sign up but you pay for
the membership and a lot of people get
membership for their memberships for
their friends family people they hate
there are outrageous conservative uncles
whoever by just going to our website
typing in the recipients name the
recipients email but you put in your
credit or debit card and then you've
just effectively sponsored a membership
now if you want to just more generally
sponsor memberships we do that all the
time people will write in they'll say
David I want to donate six hundred
dollars and sponsor ten $60 a year
memberships for example and then I will
give the memberships away on the show in
some way or sometimes people will
sponsor like half of a bunch of
memberships or whatever so we do and you
can get in touch with me Matthew if you
want to do that on a larger scale but if
you just want to get somebody a
membership you can do that with the
system that we have voh do you worry
about reaching a maximum audience
membership saturation limit
I do but we're very far from that we
estimate that under one percent of the
audience our members which is
disappointing because from the surveys
that we've done we estimate that 80% of
the audience can afford two bucks a
month which is what a membership costs
if you use the coupon code save thirty
five we uh estimate 80% of the audience
can afford membership and under one
percent of the audience actually
as a paid membership which is fine I
mean I I'm doing the show I don't need
everybody to sign up but the membership
saturation is so low that if we could
even go from 1% of the audience being
paid members to 2% it's a total
GameChanger
right I mean that doubles our membership
support so I we are very very very far
from reaching the maximum audience
membership saturation limit also is it
too late to apply for reddit moderator
status no Theo you can get in touch use
the contact form on our website and send
me a link I even have a couple of other
people that have asked about that send
me a link to your reddit profile and we
will get back to you our team on reddit
will be reviewing those those
solicitations Billy Vanilli
isn't it possible that obstruction
prevented Muller from proving conspiracy
especially if Trump was dangling pardons
this is not being discussed yeah I mean
here so you're completely right Billy
the reason I'm not really talking about
that is it's so speculative and there's
so much that we know like we know that
Moeller was not able to exonerate Trump
from obstruction and we know that the
bar letter was a public relations
document extraordinarily partisan
extraordinarily biased extraordinarily
incomplete focusing on that I think
maybe makes more sense than what you're
saying which is completely plausible
which is if Trump succeeded in
obstructing it could prevent Muller from
proving that there was a conspiracy to
collude you're making a very good point
if the obstruction was successful then
it would prevent fully investigating
conspiracy but at this point we'll have
time for that we'll have time for that I
think is my point
Jason MSU I'd pay for tickets I'd pay
for you would pay for oath like fo r I
would pay for tickets to see you debate
Kyle kolinsky about Russia I really
don't know that there is much to debate
I mean basically what what what I've
been 95% of what I've been saying would
happen has happened and uh
we need to see that report and I think
Kyle agrees with that and I think we
agree that counting on Russia to get
Trump removed is not a good electoral
strategy for Democrats yeah
and a $2 super chat that is from a user
who is unknown a viewer who is unknown
and who has retracted their message
Ramiro's on Ramirez on 145 says I'm
curious about your views on the
emoluments clause and if this is why
they are going after Trump's tax returns
do you agree with Congress on going this
route Thanks
I agree with Congress doing anything
they can to get Donald Trump's tax
returns although I would not expect to
see evidence evidence of emoluments
violations in the tax returns and the
reason why is that we know that Donald
Donald Trump has an interest in the
hotel in DC for example the revenue the
income that he earns from that is going
to show up generally on his tax returns
depending on how that business is
organized or it might not it might only
be showing up on the hotel's tax returns
but you're not going to prove that the
emoluments clause has been violated by
looking at Trump's personal tax returns
in all likelihood in all likelihood
Donald Trump's tax taxes are organized
in such a way that you would not see
evidence of individual dignitaries and
world leaders staying at Trump's hotels
and you would still have to prove that
that violates the emoluments clause it
you're just not going to see it on the
tax returns it's basically the the point
that I'm trying to make but I still
agree with trying to get the tax returns
and I think it'll heavily heavily
trigger Donald Trump since more than
likely the tax returns would show that
he is not nearly as wealthy as he claims
to be are no durn is a new YouTube
member which gets us to four new members
for the evening I will open the phone
lines when we get to ten and there are
two coupon codes in play right now okay
it is very
very very cheap to become a david pakman
show member okay when I had a birthday
on February 2nd we did a membership
discount where if you selected the $60 a
year membership the coupon code save 35
would drop that membership to just 25
bucks the the special is over in terms
of promotion but the coupon code still
works okay if you use the coupon code
save 35 on a $60 a year membership
you're paying 25 bucks a year that's two
dollars and eight cents a month for
everything that we do it's hugely
supportive of the show it allows us to
not worry about YouTube D monetization
by the way we have a clip coming out
about YouTube ad pocalypse 2.0 which is
really really bad and you get an extra
show every day called the bonus show
which is only for our paid subscribers
so please please subscribe and joy calfy
just has making her new member number
five of the evening so we're halfway
there
if people want the phone lines opened we
are halfway there five out of ten
members and you know what because I see
so many people challenging me in chess
as well on ly chess org if we get to ten
new members I will take a chess
challenge when while we wait for people
to queue up on the phones okay and if
you want to be first on the phone lines
when you sign up include your area code
in either the first or last name field
so that that way when I see your name
I'll see your area code when we open up
the phone lines you will get priority
and I will take your phone call first
mark Goodbody says if you did manage to
double the income of the david pakman
show P ACK oh boy how would you use the
extra revenue to expand your journalism
you know one thing I would really like
to do is the david pakman show continues
on our sort of steady level of what we
would call organic audience growth which
means that every month we're adding
between ten and twenty thousand
subscribers on youtube we're adding
members most months although not every
month some month we see
a dip depending on what's going on
Twitter followers Facebook all of that
stuff we are we've been organically
growing if we had new revenue above and
beyond our current level we would be
able to start doing paid promotion of
YouTube channels so you might go over to
you know how
Praeger you ads show up on the david
pakman show youtube channel and we have
no control over the ads that show up we
would then have a budget to regularly
advertise our clips on Ben Shapiro
videos on Praeger you videos and you
really need if you don't have a
significant budget to throw at that
you're not going to move the needle
because even if we throw you know a
couple hundred bucks in promotion at a
video that only gets you a few thousand
views which when we are at the time at
the current time getting 10 million
views a month buying a few thousand
views doesn't really move the needle but
if we had a nice budget for that we
could plaster Ben Shapiro's videos and
Praeger you and Molyneux and all of
these right Dave Rubin
so that when people go to watch their
videos before a video of me pops up
piercing their echo chamber and if we
really had the money to throw it that we
could do the same thing on Facebook we
could do the same thing on Twitter we
would accelerate the growth of our
audience significantly and that's one of
the things I would love to do if we can
grow a an advertising budget in that way
hal and i see based on this logo this
looks like hal from 2001 2001 a space
odyssey not only a terrific Stanley
Kubrick film but one of my favorite
favorite science fiction books by arthur
c clarke i've actually read the there's
four of them so it's not a trilogy it's
I guess a a quadrilogy a four book set
2001 2010 2061
and three thousand one it's one of my
favorite science fiction series anyway
hal sends ten bucks with no question or
comment thank you very much I appreciate
that the progressive voice is here with
a dollar ninety nine super chat would
you debate Vegeta on cyan supremacy I
don't even know what language that
I have no clue what the progressive
voice is asking about Vegeta is that
like some kind of vegetarian activist I
have no clue what that is on cyan cyan
cyan scion supremacy I just have no clue
what that is I hope it's not extremely
racist because that would be
embarrassing but I know the progressive
voice would never do that never do that
to me debar new with a two Canadian
dollar super shot just a thank you for
another live stream thank you very much
I appreciate that
Channing foo got a or Fugate early
thoughts on Pete Buddha jej today's
bonus show okay on today's bonus show
which is for our members we talked about
the articles that have come out recently
in favor of Pete Buddha judge and the
articles that have come out against Pete
Buddha judge and I think that here's so
I'm gonna do a deep dive on his policy
platform at some point relatively soon
here's what I think is uh the left is
kind of missing the boat on one element
of P Buddha Jed's identity okay there
are some people who are saying okay Pete
Buddha judge is a gay man I'm so beyond
I'm so enlightened that I'm beyond
caring what our presidents sexual
orientation is I care about the issues
stop talking to me about him being a gay
man and I think that we really need to
strike a balance where it's perfectly
fine listen Bernie Sanders is not in my
top three because he's Jewish
Andrew yang is not in my top three
because he's Asian and Elizabeth Warren
is not in my top three because she's a
woman I care about policy but if any of
them were elected it would still be
notable and relevant that we have our
first Jewish president or our first
female president for our first Asian
president so with pita judge it's not
that we don't care that he is a gay man
in terms of what it would mean for the
country where gay marriage wasn't even
legal in all 50 states a few years ago
and you can still by the way be fired in
many states for the perception of your
sexual orientation be it accurate or not
for us to have a gay president but we
can at the same time say
I wouldn't vote for him if I didn't
agree with his policy because of his
identity and I think it's really
important to distinguish those two
things and I've seen some kind of weird
weird takes from some people about it
let me say another thank you - what is
this a sickie chicky chicky Hasselblad I
hope I'm pronouncing that correctly
sicky Hasselblad has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership and sickie
has used the coupon code SAVE 35 meaning
that sickie is paying just 25 bucks for
a year membership and that is new member
number 6 of the evening we are 60% of
the way to me opening up the phone lines
I have already said I will do I will
take one chest challenge you can
challenge me on Leach s org I am David
Pakman on Leech s org if we get to 10
new members I will play one game of
chess against somebody in the audience
while we get people queued up on the
phones and we're 60% of the way there
which is very exciting
let me see if there are people leaving
voicemails people always start calling
in even before I've opened up the phone
lines and sometimes there are funny
voicemails that end up in the queue
yeah there actually are a few here but I
don't know sometimes they have swears
let's just take a listen to one of them
and see what people are saying because
the phone lines are not yet open let's
see here I'd like you to discuss the
SAFE Act to secure and fare enforcement
Banking Act that's being proposed in the
house to allow banks to finance the
cannabis industry hmm okay that's
excellent it's actually an interesting
interesting thing I will look into that
who else is leaving voicemails we're not
open the phone lines are not yet open
we're waving this is for a few new
members I'm from Pittsburgh
yeah the college thing do you know the
Vietnam War they is a military
industrial complex a and they identified
the troublemakers as being
rewards college students second first
and second generation of European
immigrants yes
okay well that's very very nuanced then
I'll have to look into that a little bit
later but I appreciate that okay the
point is we will open up the phone lines
if we get four more four more new
members tjf eight sixteen with a
five-dollar super Chad Bernie supporter
here why hasn't Bernie released his tax
returns yet his reticence is starting to
make me nervous I'm not nervous but he's
got to release it okay i Bernie's in my
top three but that is not going to
impact the the reality that he's got to
release the tax returns he said he would
Trump said he would Trump didn't we
slammed him for it
Bernie's got a release attack I mean
he's just got to do it and I wish I had
more to say but I'm not nervous but he's
got to release them and we're gonna have
a problem if he doesn't Shaun Geiss says
polls show the molar report results
didn't phase the American public in
their view of Trump well Shawn nobody's
seen the molar report remember what
you're talking about is polls show that
William bars propaganda letter may not
have fazed the American public Shawn
goes on to say wouldn't it be likely
then that Trump using his exoneration on
the 2020 trail be pointless I'm not sure
I know what you mean but I think the
important thing to remember is that we
have not no one has seen the report yet
so all we have right now to go on is how
people are reacting to a very biased
partial incomplete politicized public
relations document which is what we got
so far from from William bar
mr. Abdi with a to British Pound
super-shot Ken Brunei a sovereign nation
have their laws yeah I mean I don't know
they they can have their laws and the
international community can respond and
and Lobby them around laws that may be
human rights violations if that's what
they want to do and public figures if
they want can call for boycotts of of
the country or businesses based there so
yes I mean Brunei can
have their laws and that that they are
not immune from the consequences of
having those laws primal with a redacted
message this message was redacted for
national security I see what you did
there yeah that's what the that's what
the molar reports going to look like if
William bar has anything to say about it
no race says admitted Russian Alexander
Dugan made the alt-right rich Spencer
published his books and Dugan appeared
on Infowars multiple times to provoke
separatists no idea what you're talking
about I'm having a hard time parsing
that but uh yeah it's I appreciate I
appreciate the support Michael Williams
sends a ten-dollar super chat thank you
very much
nunya bidness sends a $10 super chat
with Trump's investigations being
portrayed as an unfair beatdown and his
base being encouraged to act out
violently
it's like Trump is attempting to mirror
the Rodney King riots
I don't think Trump knows anything about
the Rodney King riots but I think what
you're accurately perceiving is that
Donald Trump has very successfully
fomented a sort of atmosphere and
ambience of being on the verge of
violence and even encouraging it
implicitly and sometimes explicitly and
I think that I hate to say it but the
way that he has discussed the
investigations has been really effective
in terms of getting his base to just be
absolutely and completely against the
the obvious story which is Muller
couldn't clear him of wrongdoing and we
still don't know what the results of
that investigation are okay let me say
thank you to another new member we have
a Miriam Stanger
Miriam Stanger is our newest member that
is number seven okay three more new
members eight nine and ten and I will
open up the phone lines and play a game
of chess I see
number of challenges coming in are
absolutely out of control on Leech s org
I am David Pakman on HS org so the plan
for the evening if people want it we're
only three members away okay my
suggestion is let's just make it happen
so that we don't fail three times in a
row to open the phone lines sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership if you
want to take advantage of the coupon
code save 35 by all means do it do it do
it I will then open the phone lines and
while people start calling in I'll play
one game of chess against somebody in
the audience they will probably crush me
if you are sending those challenges
don't cancel them because if you do I
won't be able to accept any later and
then we will go to the phones for a
while until I have to go so we're just
three three new members away Jason
MSU says super chats should go towards
the membership goal somehow yeah I don't
I don't really know how to do that and
the thing about suit you know what the
reason that we prioritize membership is
that for a program like ours being able
to plan revenue is just so important
when we think about can we hire people
can we make investments in
infrastructure that have ongoing costs
so super chats are awesome and they're
really appreciated and they're a great
way to get interaction going with people
and answer questions and read comments
during a stream but when we get members
you know every ten new members we get on
average is somewhere between you know
it's a couple of hundred bucks of
additional revenue a year and overtime
that helps us to kind of estimate what
revenue we can count on and that's why
we prioritize memberships of any kind
during the live streams but I understand
what you're saying it would be I'm open
to ideas about how to integrate super
chats into the membership goal Kimmy
says what's your elo rating in chess you
know I don't remember if elo refers I
mean listen my I'm rated depending on
whether you're talking about bullit
blitz rapid or classical and which
website between nine hundred and
thirteen fifty different time controls
and different websites and you know I
tend to play different time controls
different times and I think generally
speaking it's common people are higher
rated for the longer time controls so
I'm not very good I'm not very good and
I have a challenge I have a couple
challenges here from people who just
have provisional ratings seems like they
probably made their account to challenge
me so they could be good they might not
be good but III very often get crushed
when I play people in the audience at
which I will do if we get three more
three more new members
less he'll feed sends a ten Swedish
kronor super chat appreciate that show
SOI Bob oh so with the dollar
ninety-nine super chat have you seen the
new Joker trailer I don't know anything
about it I have not seen it I couldn't
tell you who's playing the Joker no I
don't know a thing about it
Sam Dean with a ten Australian dollar
super chat g'day mate do you think the
lack of healthy habits that Trump seems
to adopt has had an impact on not only
his health but the world perception of
his physical state the guy seems pretty
out of it yeah I mean listen we've
talked to mental health professionals
who believe Donald Trump is in some kind
of pre dementia state or a state of
early cognitive decline or some kind of
personality disorder or there's a lot of
different speculation I don't know if
the fact that Trump never exercises and
eats fast food all the time is a part of
that I don't know that that would have
anything to do with the pre dementia it
would would the fact that he is
borderline obese if not if not actually
obese but uh I I don't know I mean I
don't know if you look at interviews
with Trump today two years ago five
years ago ten years ago in twenty years
ago there's more than just he's 72 now
there's there's definitely something
more than that although you know what
exactly it is I wouldn't be able to say
Mark P with a ten British pound super
job David you mentioned Stanley Kubrick
do you think a Clockwork Orange as
portrayal of dystopian violence and
mind-control has come true and one pound
of my donation is in tribute to your
white and gray knitwear yeah this is I
read in a medical journal that I think
I'm wearing what's called a Henley is
that is that true I don't even know I
don't know what I'm wearing but I
appreciate that I think there are
elements of Clockwork Orange at least
superficially that you can identify in
modern there's an interesting term that
I read the other day
surveillance capitalism and I know that
it's not a perfect analogy to Clockwork
Orange but there's definitely themes in
Clockwork Orange that are notable today
December asks are you worried water is
turning frogs homosexual you know I'm
not it's really not I'm not concerned
that it's happening and I'm not
I've not seen evidence that it's
happening and it's not the water it's
the fluoride I think that Alex Jones
asserted was what was turning the
turning the frogs homosexual okay we
have new member number eight of the
evening
Cheryl child's Cheryl child's is new
member number eight of the evening we
are now two members away from opening
the phone lines and me playing just one
game of chess against somebody on from
the audience on leach s org we had a 14
or so live stream in a row streak of
getting ten new members and opening the
phone lines and the last two streams we
failed to achieve ten new members let's
not make it three in a row okay we're
only two new members away and I will
open the phone lines I will let people
call in and the voicemails keep coming
in but the the phone lines are not open
just two to go okay if two people sign
up at david pakman.com slash membership
we will open the phone lines and i will
hear from people and i'd like to be able
to take calls for at least a half hour
but for that to be possible we kind of
got to make it happen pretty soon hassan
jf asks what are your thoughts on
leftists accusing people of signal
boosting the far right involving Joe
Rogan's guests or Greenwald going on
Tucker Carlson leftists accusing people
of signal boosting the far right
involving two Rogen's guests so is the
argument that when
when a left-wing guest goes on rogen
people on the Left promote it and then
it has some negative impact or are you
saying that if Greenwald goes on Tucker
it's not good for people to promote it
because it's still Fox and I'm not sure
I totally understand I tend not to do
too much promotion of that stuff unless
I have sort of like a some kind of
critique of it and then I feel like I'm
responsibly platforming the content but
I don't know that I fully understand the
question exactly as you're asking it I
log man I or one log man one David first
time donating ever
heads up destiny is debating some people
on Twitch tonight going to be fun keep
up the good work that's interesting let
me see if I can pull that up and we'll
see what's going on Destiny's twitch uh
oh boy things are just not going well
here with my various browser tabs
Destiny's twitch where can I see what's
going on with destiny the channel is for
mature audiences well that's all that's
great is in the frame of mind or they're
able to go into a my stress and vote
your god are you looking normal people
go into this high-stress environment and
they come out oh my god yes be or other
kinds of issues I just don't think
that's the best thing for what we're
trying to achieve whether that is okay
so wow thank you for calling this
bringing this to my attention so there's
a guy named Osman gold no clue who that
is obviously destiny I know Steven banal
were in touch personally my son I know I
was just texting with him this morning
actually Karl Benjamin also known as
Sargon of Akkad I know Nick Jeff went s
don't know who that is in trainwreck TV
I don't know who that is let's just
let's just listen to a little bit of
this and see what's happened do you
think that it will actively work against
it just for the you know to get down
your your position a little bit more I
do I do believe it'll work against that
alright no son what do you think one of
my favorite topics I mean yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna throw it up to destiny in a
second the only thing I was going to say
is that unfortunately the the way to
military industrial complex is set up
the unite
States currently treats the the United
States military is a jobs program and
the Department of Defense is the largest
like single body that hires the most
trans people worldwide and the fact all
right we're gonna get away from that
just because I don't know that my
audience really cares about that too
much but there's some wacky wacky stuff
going on there I had no idea that that
was going on but I appreciate you
telling me about it okay Charles Nieves
meaning which means snows in Spanish but
not snows like it's snowing like here
are a bunch of snows has signed up that
is new member number nine of the evening
and I am very very pleased to say that
Miko piss Paula is new member number ten
of the evening so this is very exciting
oh and Amanda Morin is also a new member
and she has submitted her area code so
if you want to call in I am opening the
phone lines right now at six one seven
eight three zero
4750 I will get to those others who
other super chats I promise but first I
agreed that I would be taking a
challenge a chess challenge on LI chess
org and I'm going to accept this
challenge from ollie New Zealand Ollie
and Z so while people call in at 6:00
178 3-0 47 50 I will play a why do I
have a provisional rating that's weird
I don't even know what time control this
oh I see it's untimed no wonder I should
probably have done a timed game because
this could take forever but let's see
how it goes as people are calling in I
will just kind of play a traditional
line that I am somewhat familiar with as
we let people get stacked up on the
phones I will go with my two nights here
and we've got a four night situation
let's see this could be like a really
good player in disguise and I could be
about to get absolutely crushed
absolutely crushed see what's going on
here
and a lot of people calling in moving
the Queen okay let me uh I think I'll
get the knight pinned here
for now although may know exactly what
to do in this particular case alright
I'm in a castle moving the night there
okay the bishop the bishop
where do I want to go next I think I'm
gonna go here attacking the Queen but
also the knight is pinned to the Queen
so even taking the night with his knight
would give me the Queen see if he falls
for it he does not all right let's see
if I go here and then he takes it then I
can go here and I'm forking it's a way I
think I win the broken this way playing
one game of chess against someone in the
audience and then we will open up the
phone line six one seven eight three
zero 4750 okay well now you just gave me
the Queen which is not as not the what
you want to be doing all right
and then I'll take here
okay do I move or do I defend no real
way to defend I guess I'll move back I'm
gonna move back here and then try to get
the Queen into the action all right so
attacking me here but I would take it
attacking here but I'd take it tacking
here I could take if I take here bishop
take so don't want to do that my best
move here if I go here I'll just move
again so that doesn't seem good
there's a free pawn right now I guess
I'll take the pawn for now there is this
fork right here if he doesn't defend
this Square which he did not I am now
able to fork of course the King will
have to move and then I will win this
rook is that right yeah I think that's
right King has to move rook goes down
now let's see does this check do
anything if I do this check King has to
move here doesn't seem super useful hmm
I go here you need to get my Queen into
the action so maybe what I'll do is
maybe I could eventually made on this
square if I can get the Queen in and
defend this square so maybe I'll just
start moving this pawn we'll be taking
calls after this six one seven eight
three zero forty seven fifty okay so now
I need to find a way to defend here so
I'll move around this way want to get
here this is the attack I'm planning so
far allowing me to do it now I've got to
get this pawn out of the way move the
Queen here so far I think I'm okay with
this plan
can't take it cuz he just loses it my
idea is to go right here nice with the
Queen okay so let's calculate this
Bishop is this Bishop is attacking my
rook if I go here and he takes the
bishop the rook I don't think I care
because then I think that this square is
mate right what else can you do so maybe
I give away the bishop the rook I'm
gonna try it I don't think I'm
miscalculating this let's see yeah
I mean this this is mate right yes it is
okay good game alright thank you for the
game appreciate it
let's go to the phone lines at six one
seven eight three zero
4750 we do have a couple of other super
chats which I will take just as we're
getting set up on the phones 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 I'm going to our new member Amanda
first if she is on the phones from the
72 zero area code is she on the phone
she's not so amanda donated made it made
a new membership noted her area code but
has not called in yet so that's ok you
don't have to call in um let's see let
me get set up here to take phone calls
want to make sure people wonder what I'm
writing when we take calls we have a
database of callers so that we know
who's calling in so I just make quick
notes while while we are taking phone
calls just so I remember who's who let's
go to let's go to the oh no you know
what Amanda is on the phone now at 7 to
0 so since she I promised that new
members would get on the phones first so
I believe that this is nope she hung up
ok I was going to Amanda but it seems as
though Amanda hung up
let's go instead to the 2 6 7 area code
who's calling today from 2 6 7
Oh didn't you hear me I can hear you
who's this oh great great this is Philip
from Philly Philly yeah um I kinda
didn't even expect you to pick up so why
is that yeah literally because why call
it in kind of late so I figured there
were like thousands of people in ahead
of me and yeah but but uh I'm going to
kind of go into a topic I super chatted
you about like a while ago ok but um
well actually let me just make one thing
clear to give some context to what I'm
about to say I was just going to bring
up the case you may have heard about the
Georgia gauge case where like a guy who
was accused of a
of sexual assault with innocent but kept
in jail for on a 70-year sentence
because Kamala you know when she had the
opportunity to you know dismiss that
case she upheld the wrongful conviction
okay um but just before I go into the
question real quick if anybody listening
now wants to kind of just brush up on
the case they can google Andrew Cohen
which is the author of this article
which summarizes the case co h en cohen
and then the guy's name is george gage
last name GA GE so if you googled george
days Andrew Cohen the Marshall project
org should be one of the first results
and that article will summarize the case
from 1999 up till now alright and love
ya what is your question today oh yeah
sorry about that my question was um you
know Bernie's my my first choice you
know I'm a Jill Stein voter in 2012 2016
I you know grudgingly supported Hillary
but you know back on the Bernie train
but Kamala my number one thing with her
is George gage and other cases of her
you know uploading wrong or try at least
trying to and other criminal justice
things you know are stopping me from I
mean I'm sure you know about her record
but do you think that you know someone
who is literally one of the people
fighting for this man release do you
think it is unreasonable for people in
my position who hold you know beliefs
against you know against some criminal
injustice do you think that it would be
unreasonable for someone like me to even
question voting for Kamala in in the in
the general assuming she actually be
Bernice um I don't think it's gonna
happen on your politics that depends on
your politics if if if Connell Harris
makes it to the general election and
your choices between
all Trump and Kamala Harris who you
disagree with and because of her role in
this case which I'm not familiar with by
the way it's I can't answer that for you
you have to evaluate what matters more I
mean I don't there's there's only one
person that can answer that and that's
you you know and you don't know the
cliche I don't think many people do so
that's understandable the only thing is
because of uh you know court packing and
me not wanting Trump to put in hundreds
more circuit judges that are like super
right wing and everything I mean that
will probably that would probably tip
the scale and make me vote for Kamala
all right but it sounds like you've got
your answer Phil I appreciate the call
I'm going to let you go I've got a bunch
of people holding I'm gonna get to let
me do so I say I think Amanda from 72
zeroes back on don't hang up AM and I'm
going to you next let me just mention
that Al's take sent a two dollar super
chat asking how the country can
reconcile its differences I have no idea
I wish I knew but that is not an area
that I have any good ideas about the
North says hi David NATO turned 70 this
years what do you think about the
Alliance is it good for the United
States I think it's good for the planet
to have those alliances and you can make
different arguments about it's better
for smaller countries it's better for
bigger countries it's better for
countries that are in NATO or out of
NATO I think that the existence of these
types of alliances is generally a good
thing and Brian Walters with a $30 super
chat the largest super chat of the
evening thirty bucks just supposing you
which I think means just supporting you
okay let's go to the 7 to 0 area code
which i think is amanda our newest
members that right hey yeah what's going
on Amanda no problem happens to the best
of us
alright well a couple things I became a
member after you mentioned that you had
the same birthday as me stuff cool yeah
but then I'm more pressingly I was
wondering if you had any theories as to
why the liberal media especially was so
accepting of the bar report when it was
very obviously
not something to be taken seriously okay
so you've got to distinguish here you've
got corporate media okay and whether
it's you know CNN MSNBC Nightly News
with whoever is doing the nightly news
on the networks now their bias is two
coherent narratives that lend themselves
to corporate media segments so when the
investigation was going on the the
coherent story was big investigation
we've got to cover it when the bar
letter came out it's almost too
complicated for corporate media to say
it's a bar letter it's not really a
summary we haven't seen the report the
report can exonerate Trump but now it's
unclear what's going to be redacted and
in any case the Southern District of New
York is continuing to investigate that
short-circuits how corporate media works
so I don't even know you know you'd have
to tell me a little more about what what
you mean by liberal media but part of it
is just corporate media's biased towards
simple narratives now there are people
on the Left who don't really watch
anything but I caught wind of there are
people who believe that that Trump was
exonerated by the Moller report even
though we haven't seen it and honestly I
don't know why they're doing that it
doesn't make any sense to me I don't get
it yeah that was basically my question
as well yeah I mean it's you know so I
think some people want to feel
vindicated there are people who
historically have predicted all sorts of
different things and any opportunity
they get to claim vindication the same
way Trump is claiming exoneration
they're going to do it but I don't get
it I don't really get it and you know
I'm waiting for the facts to come out
I'm just hoping they do I hope so - all
right Amanda I appreciate your support
and thanks for being a new member yeah
thank you all right we're gonna mark
Amanda down as a good caller in the
phone system I think we can say that
with with certitude let's go next to the
2-0 to area code who's calling today
from - zero - oh can you hear me yes I
can't who's this oh this is Danielle oh
it's such an honor to speak with you mr.
Pakman thanks really appreciate
everything he's done thus far I'm 23
years old I was born in the Bahamas and
I grew up in Georgia and
yeah so my first question is about
reparations you know I'm kind of I
consider myself to be non bias on this
issue because I wouldn't qualify for
them anyway because I'm not a American
to send it but I was wondering if you
had a chance to formulate an opinion on
Cory Booker's response to reparation and
if you had your own opinion on what
ideal reparations would look like if
there are as you know I don't know what
it would ideally look like so what I
know is that I don't have a problem with
the concept of reparations the questions
the question marks I have right now are
how far do they extend and how many
generations that's number one
number two do they what other in
justices are we willing to address via
reparations I'm not suggesting every
every historical injustice is the same
I'm just saying there must be more than
merely a black slavery that need that
could be addressed by reparations so I
would want to know how do we define
which circumstances should be addressed
via reparations and then number three
will it actually solve structural
disadvantages that exist for many black
Americans because that that would be my
priority I want to fix the structural
disadvantages that exist so I don't have
any part in any proposal any particular
proposal I'll look at and evaluate I
don't have one of my own though I agree
a hundred percent because I've seems to
be one of my major concern concerns it's
like when people talk about reparations
the first idea people get is you know
handing them big wads of money and doing
different things like that and that just
causes such fear in my heart because I'm
like that would be disastrous
I really would want to see ways to study
and tackle structural racism and make
sure that you know things benefit for
further generations to come but you know
I really appreciate you talking to me
and you and Calculon skee are so cute
and so I really appreciate you guys
giving us sexy news and thank you so
much mister pack of it I'll talk to you
later all right thank you David please
call me David I think we're on we're
certainly now on a first on a first-name
basis for sure okay a couple other super
chats
phrenic 32 says when des is a 1/4
Hispanic with nationale Asst couldn't
have said it better myself
Ella Grasso says yo David Pakman
you're a true homie smog trees smog
trees Miko piss Paula says new member
please pick up code 3 5 8 from Finland
let me see I don't see any country code
3 5 I don't see anything that resembles
that right now and if by the way if
you're calling from Skype it wouldn't
show me that there's a couple people
holding from Skype and if what you're
one of those Miko it wouldn't show me
three five eight because it just shows
this generic generic Skype number
mitchell valdez sends a twenty mexican
peso super chat como sick is enough
where pat the hundo diggin out it he's
asking how does he know that the person
i just beat on in chess wasn't wasn't
pat you know i i don't know for sure but
i think pat might have played a little
bit better this was this was a very
inexperienced player based on based on
how the game went so i think that that
alone tells me it wasn't Pat I think Pat
would not have fallen for such an
obvious attempt by me for a what I would
call it cheap checkmate okay let's go
next to okay Jimmy from Philly is
holding I'm going to let the audience
decide in the regular chat whether I
pick up on Jimmy from Philly because
maybe people are sick of Jimmy from
Philly okay so let me know in the chat
I'm gonna take up Quick Poll first
twenty comments yes or no will determine
whether I pick up on Jimmy from Philly
let's see here one no to knows three
knows one yes
five to one no six to one no seven to
one no seven to two eight nine ten
eleven he's just it's it's a no but you
know I still kind of want to hear from
him I'll go to someone else first
but maybe I'll get to Jimmy in a little
bit let me go to valve from Agawam valve
from Agawam is next on always great to
hear from Val
hi David how are you doing good how you
doing I was out in western mass over the
weekend by the way the pot shops are
everywhere now yeah they are for sure
actually that was one of my questions do
you get to visit the home of the the
original home of the David Pakman show
very often I do I do I was there over
the weekend it was my mom's birthday it
was my sister's birthday and I get back
to Western Mass about every three weeks
and you can tell it's just it's I can't
speak for Agawam maybe Agawam is sort of
lefty but feeding Hills I think is more
conservative I don't remember exactly
but Northampton is very very liberal and
out there I go people are saying love
the show love the show so it's always a
good time to be back in and the behind
the tofu curtain as I like to say yeah
yeah that's great
I was just wondering how long you think
you will wait before deciding on
supporting a certain candidate in other
words are you going to choose to wait to
the debates do you think it might be
even later than that you're not sure
here's the thing number one I need to be
sure that all of the candidates that
have a shot at winning have declared and
I don't know for sure that that's the
case right now and obviously you know
Joe Biden is the question mark there
beyond that I don't know that I need to
wait until the debates necessarily
there's kind of diminishing marginal
utility of more and more information at
a certain point I'm going to just be
able to decide but I don't know I'm not
gonna wait inordinate ly long I'll all
be clear about who I'm supporting it'll
be a sort of a go with your gut sort of
thing in the end it's going to kill know
when you know I'll know when I know
that's exactly right you know it's going
to be it's an unknown known unknown to
take a page out of Donald Rumsfeld's
vocabulary it's something I don't know
when I know I don't know when I'll know
and I don't know how I'll know but I
know I'll know if that makes sense which
of course it doesn't bail no believe it
or not David I understand that oh okay
if it or not great to hear from you Val
thank you thank you take care okay
bye-bye
great to hear from Val from the the
world's first zip code Oh 100 won all
right let me see what Jimmy from Philly
has to say Jimmy what what you got for
me today all right so I want to hear
your answer to this question okay so
okay mauler who else again when you call
me by the way what sister who else's
answer would you expect to get when
you're calling me David come on man that
I won't interrupt you a few longer or
interrupt me is that a very generous
there we go here we go David Marlo was
smoking he came to a conclusion on
collusion with no conclusion on
obstruction mower came to a conclusion
on collusion he said there was no
conclusion okay okay but the ball wait
wait he passes the ball on obstruction
to bar why do you think he did there's a
couple different reasons why he might
have done it
number one is Moeller knows bar doesn't
believe a sitting president can be
indicted for obstruction so knowing that
molar might just say why am I even gonna
bother let me just turn it over to
William Bar even though it shouldn't
even really be up to bar should be up to
the house another possibility is that
molar is simply unsure whether the
political ramifications are worth it I
mean I I would be depressed if that's
the reality but you might have robert
muller just saying my instinct would be
to say yes on obstruction but the it
could potentially tear the country apart
so to speak but I don't know no I don't
think mowers a guy that cares about
tearing the country apart
look look who we hired the staff is a
investigative team I mean he didn't care
about optics regarding any of that
who did he hire they all hated Trump all
well there's Peter struck but who else
what do you mean this whole team well
here's the reason David
more and put out a memo a while ago
claiming that he didn't think Trump was
guilty of obstruction who did a reason
why more passed the football to bar was
because you guys would run around the
way you are now it's unfair it's it's
that they're kidding you and of course
Dave you're asking people I think we're
gonna get the full report knowing full
well we're not going to get to by law we
can't get the full report
so why what law says we can't you can't
get grand jury testimony you can't get
any kind of classified information you
can't get any that's okay are they will
Jimmy so it sounds like we have a
gentleman's disagreement on this issue
no you're just wrong
oh alright well thank you for the call
Jimmy great to hear from people in the
chat have turned it's gotten ugly people
are very much against Jimmy people are
now saying that it used to be funny but
that they're not really liking the Jimmy
stuff anymore which it has gotten very
very ugly very very ugly okay Jacob Ball
is asking via super chat with a twenty
dollar and ninth nineteen cents uber
chat did David secretly arranged for Pat
to be the one he anonymously played in
chess so they could rig it to make David
look good in chess hash tag chess Kate
2019
no I that was I mean listen if that was
Pat unbeknownst to me then I feel bad
for Pat but that that was not bad
Sabrina so far asks favorite Boston area
cafes and restaurants oh man you know I
don't want to give away too many of them
because I don't want people starting to
show up at them and then ruining places
that I like to go but I've mentioned
Michaels deli in Brookline Jewish style
deli get the corned beef can't go wrong
with the corned beef say hi to Steve
when you're there tell them David Pakman
sent you there's a place in Jamaica
Plain called the noodle barn which has
the best tom yum soup love tom yum soup
and they have really really good tom
soup there is a great expensive but
really great sushi place downtown called
oh yah which has a sort of a tasting
menu which is extraordinary
Yankee lobster company Yankee lobster
Market Yankee lobster house it's out on
the Seaport is a fantastic seafood place
there are two restaurants that are sort
of Mediterranean tapas Oh Liana and
Sarma I think they're owned by the same
people one is in Somerville one's in
Cambridge which are excellent there are
so many there are just so many Cafe I'm
not gonna say cafes because I don't want
people showing up and harassing me when
I'm just trying to work on my laptop you
know that's not not what I'm looking for
let's go to our caller from the 631 area
code who's calling today from 631 that's
me Charles Nieves our new subscriber
number 9 oh hey what's going on Charles
hey not much so thank you for taking my
call thank you for hosting this pleasure
um I guess I have a to thank you I guess
I got two questions really quick so one
Tim Ryan just entered the race today and
I just logged on late so if you already
talked about having talked about sorry
but uh okay so I guess number one what
do you think of Tim Ryan's chances and
number two little cause I'm a little
passionate about but I feel like it gets
like no traction whatsoever and I get it
as so many things that you know get
everybody is on everybody's plate but
last week fish and wildlife just
released a record about Red Bulls which
there's only 24 to 35 of them left in
the wild
so basically long story short they were
trying to do a study to determine
whether the Red Wolf was a coyote hybrid
and a study basically says their unique
species so Fish and Wildlife has been
punting on them now for the last several
years what do you think it would take to
actually get some attention to an animal
that again is so endangered you know I
think back we used to have California
condors were so endangered yeah how
people rally to them but they don't now
yeah I don't know what it would take I
mean it's like I can talk about it but I
mean talking about it isn't isn't enough
oftentimes you know it's a coherent
story that you need when it
the animals you often need some
individual stories of of animals that
could be told that needs to be sort of a
generally cuddly or cute animal in some
way I mean you know the standard sort of
media propaganda stuff applies as far as
Tim Ryan I've met him personally there's
an interview with him I did in person on
my youtube channel I really liked him I
think he's super smart I think he has a
lot of really good ideas I don't think
his chances are very good quite frankly
Charles Goddard yeah I kind of figured
as much I mean you know he does seem to
be I guess not where the party is going
right now and you know I guess I wonder
sometimes why some of these people
bother one day you know I'm guessing
they have to be able to read the tea
leaves somewhere right yeah I think
privately they know what their chances
are but they maybe say I've got a 1%
chance that people start paying
attention to me and if not there's some
advantage to my career to running right
I think that's the calculation sometimes
honestly it's an unsuccessful
presidential run makes it easier for
them to get reelected in the House or
Senate god I will thank you so much for
taking my call yeah thank you I
appreciate it
Brian Walters sends a super chat saying
Jimmy from Philly is still funny to me
good because a lot of people very much
turning against him let's go to our
caller from the two-seven-zero area code
who's calling today from two seven zero
two seven zero maybe you have your phone
muted I don't know we can't hear you two
seven zero going once
two seven zero going twice two seven
zero was not there two seven zero was
simply not there okay I'm gonna randomly
pick up a Skype call this is like
Russian Roulette and there's multiple
people holding so you'll have to ask me
is this me I know that's annoying for
the audience but a Skype caller who's
there that's me
it is you hey David this is miles hey
miles
so number one first what's your opinion
on Tim pulled the YouTuber guy I don't
really like him but what about you
personally he's always been nice to me
I don't really watch his content so I
can't really say and I've seen I mean I
see some of his head like I'm friends
with him on Facebook and a lot of the
stuff I see just superficially seems
anti left to me although I know he says
he's an independent journalist but on a
personal level he's always been penny
nice to me yeah all right and your
opinion on Joe Biden's harassment
allegations I don't know if they're
assault but these allegations that Joe
Biden inappropriately touched people
your opinion yep so listen I've seen the
videos Joe Biden has behaved in a way
that by today's standards are
inappropriate and maybe by any standards
should have always been inappropriate
but but just weren't I think that every
single person who says they were made
uncomfortable by what joe biden did is
absolutely beyond reproach if they were
uncomfortable than they were
uncomfortable and joe biden needs to
recognize that i think that the the
problem I have with it is that there's
no indication whatsoever that Joe Biden
has assaulted anyone there's no
indication whatsoever that this is even
a fraction of what Donald Trump is
accused of and there's every indication
that what what Joe Biden is accused of
is what he's on camera doing right he
touches people's shoulders and he'll get
in close and I know people who do stuff
like that and and I know that it's it's
not comfortable for everybody and I
don't like it so I think that everyone
who says Joe Biden made them
uncomfortable is completely right and
Joe Biden needs to account for that but
we've got a president in the Oval Office
who's accused of sexually assaulting you
know 12 to 15 women so anybody from
Laroy yeah who is talking about this
like Oh Joe can't be President because
of it is a total hypocrite well yeah I
mean here's the thing I'm not saying
like what Joe did is anything close to
what Donald Trump did but I'm not
supporting him after this after thing I
would I wouldn't support it is up I
don't know anyway okay so final question
was did you ever give your thoughts on
the Amazon
hq2 thing in New York and if you and I
guess if you didn't what are your
thoughts on the idea I did I covered it
pretty extensively so I don't want to
rehash it now but basically my thought
was if if if New Yorkers don't want it
there then don't put it there amazon has
any number of places they can go I think
the way Amazon played it was basically
to just get offers for for tax
incentives and they played it in a way
that ultimately is going to benefit them
and you know if New York doesn't want it
why force it on them it's totally fine I
think that their net effect on wherever
it goes would probably be positive for
the economy although I understand the
effect on housing prices and traffic
congestion is is not the best but yeah I
have commented on it miles okay well one
last thing Michael Cohen said he wants
to delay prison meet it meeting like to
appear on Capitol Hill again just wanted
to mention that Michael Cohen might be
coming back for a second testimony okay
all right - thank you for letting me
know I appreciate that always great to
always great to hear from Miles and on
that note that does it for this evening
thanks to everybody who signed up called
in sent messages super chats all of that
stuff I'll be streaming again before you
know it